[Musique]
à l'heure où les collégiens de Lille
font encore des gracces matinées les
agents du Département sont en action
bien avant la rentrée dans le collège
Émile Hugo ces 12 super agents
s'activent dans un panel de
[Musique]
métier on part du principe dégradation
plus vite on la supprime mux c'est bien
sûr donc faut montrer aux élèves que il
y a en permanence un un
suivi on va dire que c'est plus calme il
y a moins de bruit on on a plus la le
temps de faire des choses qu'on peut pas
faire en temps normal parce que bon
quand les comme les élèves sont pas là
on est on peut faire du bruit on peut
faire tout ce qu'on com ce qu'on a
besoin de faire on a du temps pour
travailler dessus quoi sur surtout sur
les travaux de maintenance euh voilà un
peu plus loin le chef de cuisine prépare
les meilleures conditions de
restauration aux élèves tout doit être
nickel à sac rentré il faut tout
nettoyer dépoussierer et tout pourquoi
bah pour niveau d'hygiène ouais niveau
d'hygiène il y a tellement de poussière
mais l'extérieur des vites aussi
l'extérieur tout tout il faut faire tout
l'extérieur intérieur tout les tout les
il reste plusà passer la grosse
vaisselle et après je sais pas s'il se
rend pas compte ou quoi mais il met la
main il met les mains sur les vitres les
mains qui sont bon il va il y a un peu
de graisse et
tout cet établissement scolaire a la
chance d'avoir des installations
sportives à disposition mais encore une
fois l'entretien y est primordial il
arrive que l'école est correct ici
l'école ici le collège ici c'est faut la
perfection hein faut ah oui ici faut la
perfection faut qu'on arrive tout les
dans le norme on a la chance en fait oui
ce collège a pourtant 18 ans la clé d'un
beau cadre de travail semble être la
cohésion de groupe vous c'est déjà un
travail d'équipe une bonne cohésion de
tous les personnels et puis une
polyvalence qu'ils obtiennent à travers
des formations qui leur seront proposées
tout au long de l'année donc cette
polyvalence elle est réinvestie et
réexploitée au niveau de l'établissement
quoi loin des regards les 83 collèges de
Lille se remettent donc en mouvement
pour entamer l'année dans les meilleures
conditions pour accompagner nos 62000
collégiens le département finance 1182
adjoint technique territoriaux des
établissements d'enseignement un vrai
atout pour sa réussite quand on est
collégien à la
[Musique]
Réunion